would the UFC want sugar to win this
fight of course he's a massive star if
he wins this makes him even bigger
there's nothing the UFC can do Saturday
night there's nothing they do to
increase his grappling capabilities
against al Joe his wrestling is good is
jitsu's phenomenal his striking could
definitely use some work and I think
that's why people try to lean towards
sugar here I think if sugar brings his a
game aljo brings his a game aljo's gonna
win that fight nine times out of ten
because of the way the rules are set up
because of the way the sport is set up a
great Grappler will usually always be a
good Striker and I saw an interview
sugar had with Brad akamoto where he
goes I have to be perfect I have to be
perfect I know I'm getting taken down
but just about surviving on the ground
when I heard that him say survive I'm
like oh I don't like that
I don't like that I don't think you can
survive on the ground with Al Joe I
think it's only a matter of time before
he gets you down I just think it's
Sterling's time but when he leaves I
think it could definitely be Sugar's
division